[Music]
now then
can you identify the man
who raped you most certainly would right
yonder
tom would you stand up please let's have
a good long look at you
tom would you catch this please
well then good enough for me
okay probably guilty i rest my case here
and i sentence you to
wait wait mr benjamin break that girl i
didn't well hold on everyone hold
on just hold on
are you certain this is the man who
raped you
sure these black is pissed well then
that settles it
guilty as sin wait wait no mr [ __ ] no
no i wasn't even there that night
my hand didn't even work you know this
tom
do you mean to tell me that you're
questioning a survivor
that's a bunch of peer baloney and you
know it don't i deserve a fair trial
it's supposed to be innocent to proven
guilty right
black lives matter too now you know yes
at one moment in time that may have been
true
but now we have to believe all women
period
i'm sorry tom there's nothing like
everyone be quiet
mr [ __ ] come back don't let him do this
to me now you're saying this man
raped you yes your honor guilty you know
i didn't do it
come on let's go you don't have the
authority dude what about
your raid my peers i'm sorry there's
nothing i can do she said you did it
brian next up
the people versus clarence thomas
you